[Music]
don't teenagers panic after seeing
pimples on their faces wait hold on why
are we discussing about pimples well
that is because it describes one of the
most significant physical changes in
adolescents an apart from this the issue
is common in both girls and boys
development of pimples and acne are very
noticeable features of adolescence again
the same question would pop up in our
minds why do these are core prominently
during adolescence only the simplest
reason is that during puberty the
activity of oil glands and sweat glands
is quite high wait a second what exactly
are these glands the first ones called
oil glands or even sebaceous glands are
those which secrete an oily substance
called sebum a mixture of various oils
and waxes is secreted by the sebaceous
glands present all over the body and
what will be the use of the sebum it is
meant to protect the skin and form a
waterproof as well as lubricating layer
around it and what to the second type of
glands function as as the name suggests
sweat glands unknown for secretion of
sweat the main purpose of this is to
maintain body temperature and eliminate
waste products to an extent if the
secretions from these glands are good
for us then how can these cause pimples
and related problems
well these secretions are good only in
the required amounts however if the
quantity of secretions exceed the
required amount then they definitely
cause problems this is what exactly
happens during puberty
since these glands secrete excessive
sebum and other oils it results in the
extra amount to ooze out of the skin
however the skin pores usually get
clogged with the extra oil and these
clogs result in the pimples or acne on
the face these were some commonly
observed changes that come with
adolescence however we have not yet
discussed the most important
physical change in every adolescent yes
I am referring to the development of sex
organs wait a second
are we saying that these organs develop
during adolescence only yes the
reproductive organs which are also
referred to as the gonads are present
since birth but develop completely
during puberty and what does this imply
it implies that the male or the female
is now physically capable of reproducing
so what exactly do we mean by
development of the reproductive organs
if we take the case of males then the
development of testes takes place this
is the site for production of male
gametes that is the sperms similarly in
case of females we find the development
of reproductive structures called
ovaries these ovaries are the location
where excels that is the OVA are
produced that is the reason why we say
that puberty is a stepping stone towards
adulthood but other changes during
adolescence limited to the physical ones
of course not we have seen that the
changes during puberty will include
mental intellectual and emotional ones
as well so what exactly will happen in
this case in order to understand this we
need to take help of the theory put
forth by the famous German American
psychologist Erik Erikson in his theory
the stage of adolescence is bestowed
with the title identity versus role
confusion his the title self-explanatory
yes it is it tells us what the
adolescents go through along with all
the physical changes adolescents
experience many changes in their
thinking patterns as well they can grasp
and learn things better and they usually
understand emotions better
psychologically they start behaving
independently at this stage many of them
find themselves confident enough to take
a few decisions as well so as per the
theory individuals during adolescence
either
successful while searching their own
identity and the responsibilities or
become totally confused as to what
exactly is happening with them in life
we know that every individual is unique
similarly characters seen in adolescents
right from physical changes to the
mental development are subjective to
each individual in simple words
adolescence is an age just like wet clay
you can mold yourself into the most
appropriate form but for this all you
need is good morals the right direction
and an elderly guide to lead you to the
correct path with this we come to an end
of the topic changes occurring during
adolescence so what next in the next
video we have to learn about the concept
of development of secondary sexual
character
[Music]